une application qui traquent chaque
interaction sociale est elle
indispensable pour enrayer la
propagation du coronavirus depuis
plusieurs semaines le gouvernement
travaille au développement d'une
application de traçage de contacts
appelés stop qu'ovide concrètement une
fois installé sur votre smartphone
l'application stop qu'ovide à permettre
à une personne qui apprend sa
contamination d'alerter les autres
utilisateurs qu'il a pu croiser à une
distance de moins d'un mètre et durant
15 minutes au cours des deux semaines
précédentes
le tout de manière complètement anonyme
pour repérer vos déplacements
l'application fonctionne sans
géolocalisation il faudra donc activer
l'option bluetooth
selon le gouvernement l'anonymat sera
préservée vie à l'utilisation d'un
pseudonyme mais l'application ne fait
pas l'unanimité stop coville suscite les
craintes de bon nombre de défenseurs de
la vie privée qui craignent qu'elle ne
marque un premier pas vers une société
de surveillance où nous faisait gestes
sont épiés en permanence par des
systèmes automatiques
de son côté la cnil considère que les
concepteurs de l'application ont érigé
un certain nombre de garde-fous pour
empêcher les dérives et a donc été
définitivement validé l'application mais
le projet continue de diviser au sein de
la société civile
selon l'observatoire data publica 49%
des français se disent prêts à installer
l'application 54 qui déclare ne pas
avoir confiance dans la manière dont les
données seront utilisées et même la
majorité a l'air om s'affiche désuni et
mal à l'aise sur le sujet des élus de
droite comme de gauche pensent que le
gouvernement s'apprête à franchir une
ligne rouge cedrico le secrétaire d'état
au numérique qui porte ce projet depuis
le début se veut rassurant il faut se
garder du fantasme d'une application
liberticide
notre hypothèse est celle d'un outil
installer volontairement et qui pourrait
être désinstallé à tout moment sa mise
en place est temporaire le décret que
nous préparons prévoit qu'elle sera
automatiquement désactivée et que les
données seront toutes effacées dans les
six mois suivant à la fin de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
l'état n'a accès à aucune donnée
identifiantes il n'y aura pas de
géolocalisation mais pas assez rassurant
pour jean marie burguburu le président
de la commission nationale consultative
des droits de l'homme l'anonymat peut
toujours être brisée par recoupement les
techniques informatiques le permettent
parfaitement le volontariat est biaisé
puisqu'il peut être soumis à des
contraintes notamment de la part des
employeurs ce système est trop fort pour
obtenir le but poursuivi
alors pour apaiser les tensions le
gouvernement a donc accepté de soumettre
l'application au vote de l'assemblée
puis du sénat selon le secrétaire d'état
chargé du numérique en cas d'avis
favorable du parlement
l'application pourrait être mise à
disposition le 2 juin
en revanche si le parlement devait
s'opposer au déploiement de ce top cow
vide
l'application ne saurait pas
téléchargeables cedrico se dit
raisonnablement confiant quand ton choix
de la majorité